[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
session today we're going to talk about
how to visualize cloud BigTable access
patterns with visual analytics and with
us today we have Steven Amos from
Twitter and we have wim de Paul an
engineering manager of Google's cloud my
name is Misha Brooklyn and I'm a product
manager on BigTable on Google cloud with
that Steve take it away thank you
all right so hey everybody I'm Steve
Neiman I'm a software engineer at
Twitter I'm a team lead for our revenue
data analytics product um we basically
focus on serving analytic queries
specifically for our advertiser
analytics so let's talk about Twitter a
little bit just a little background for
people unfamiliar with it so we have
around 300 plus million monthly active
users of those users they're generally
generating around 100 million tweets per
day that turns into something like 300
petabytes of data that we have stored on
HDFS and we're a global company we have
pops in over five continents
um so specifically now let's talk about
advertiser analytics so we have all
those users interacting on the platform
our advertiser analytics product is what
we use to provide to our advertisers in
order to get information on how their
ads and campaigns are performing so they
can see things like spend spend break
down impressions clicks all these
metrics in real time through you guys
that we provide to them and also api's
for our more advanced advertisers so the
scale that we operate on here is is
pretty large we have over hundreds of
thousands of active advertisers at any
given times those advertisers are
running lots of campaigns and all those
campaigns are generating hundreds of
thousands of events per second those
could be coming from client events from
their web browsers mobile apps all that
stuff but even internal applications
that we have like our AB serving
infrastructure those are all generating
events that go through our pipeline so
all in all it's around 20 terabytes a
day of
log data and our pipelines will take
that and compress it down and aggregate
it to about eight terabytes a year of
data so in all our analytic data set
sizes is somewhere on the order of 50
terabytes but growing as we speak right
now so let's talk about what are the
requirements that we need to provide in
the SLO as we try to achieve for this
analytic service that we provide the
queries need to be fast so these things
are powering interactive you eyes
they're powering API is that our
advertisers using so we try to shoot for
pretty tight SFA's our SLA is a 4.5
seconds on many of these queries pretty
much all of the queries which can be
forgiving uh
hourly or give me the last week of data
I'm just aggravated together we
generally have around 5,000 QPS which
turns into around a gigabyte a second of
data that we're processing at any given
time just for query execution and we we
obviously have a pretty high SLO on
uptime 9 997 let's talk more about the
queries we're serving here so things
like give me all of the impressions that
my Promoted Tweets have generated for
the last seven days
show me the spend that my campaigns have
had over the last month totaled up and
some together let's say give me the
impressions by day for only app installs
by iOS users um so we get really
granular with some of these queries and
can break them down and segment them
many ways and then other things like
hourly spend broken down by geography so
like how much of people in Japan spent
on uh on tweets all of these things can
turn into some problems that we'll run
into when we try to scale system
off-the-shelf systems up the
dimensionality of this data is very high
we have at least twenty hide and high
cardinality dimensions things like
geography interests things like that and
additionally we also have another twenty
or so lower cardinality dimensions that
we need to query over so a lot of the
systems we've looked at
weren't really designed for this level
of QPS and latency um they were more for
ad-hoc internal analytics of like maybe
there's a DEA that's trying to do some
investigation and is just running a
couple queries for a minute
so that brings us to why we used a cloud
BigTable we decided to use this as our
analytic database and basically build
analytic product on top of it so reasons
we chose it it's fully managed which is
awesome like we don't have to run any
hardware we don't have to run any
software I don't have to worry about
upgrading it ever all of that's handled
for us it's very scalable and it's very
easy to scale I can just go into the UI
or use the API or whatever and add
another 20 nodes and scale up my cluster
by 20% and it it just happens instantly
I don't have to worry about
requisitioning hardware and and getting
that kind of stuff it's very high
performance it's it's basically linearly
scalable to any size assuming you have
good key design which we'll talk about
later in this and the the actual schema
and the design of the system makes it
really well sorted for the high
performance time series analytics that
we want to do so with that I'm gonna
hand it over to Misha to talk more about
BigTable thank you Steve so let's talk
about Google Cloud BigTable and the
feature said that it provides to enable
Steve and his team to do the analytics
at scale so what is BigTable BigTable is
a sparse distributed persistent
multi-dimensional sorted map that's the
description that you can see in the
paper from 2006 so let's dive into
details for a bunch of these different
attributes and see how they work in
practice BigTable is a distributed key
multi value store it is sparse in a
sense that unwritten cells don't take up
any space so you don't have to fill out
every single cell in every single row
for every single column family it
supports atomic single row transactions
so you can modify any values across any
of the column families and it has a
single index which is the row keys there
are no secondary indices for any of the
columns that you see except for the
Royal key in this table you can see how
you would access the different cells in
the table by using the row key column
family and column qualifier to uniquely
identify them
copic table supports the
multi-dimensional map model as follows
for a tuple of values the row which is a
string a column which is a combination
of column family and an optional column
qualifier together with an n64 timestamp
given all of those values you can
retrieve the value and the value is an
under tray on interpreting array of
bytes and so here you can see that you
have a built-in time dimension that you
can use to store time series in fact
while most databases are 2-dimensional
picked it was actually three dimensional
so the third dimension in big table is
time every cell has an arbitrary number
of versions and there's an n64 attached
to each one of those cell versions you
can treat them as time you can also
treat them as an arbitrary version ID so
you could just give them numeric
incrementing numbers you can store an
arbitrary number of them but you can
also enable automatic garbage collection
either based on time or based on count
so you don't have to manually go in and
clean up and delete the unnecessary
values you can keep just writing into a
big table set up policy and big table
will asynchronously remove data after
some time or after you've reached the
limit such as you say keep the last 5
values and big table automatically
garbage collect them asynchronously over
time
let's talk about the request routing
mechanism in BigTable BigTable clients
connect to a single endpoint which is
the load balancing proxy layer and it
then forwards the request to the
BigTable knows to serve the data in the
following set of slides I'm going to
remove the load balancing proxy layer
for clarity but keep in mind that
clients don't necessarily connect
directly to the victor bundles the
requests are routed through this API
layer so here you can see the clients
are connecting to BigTable BigTable
doesn't actually store in your data
which is kind of interesting for a
database victim would self a stateless
because it stores all the data in
Colossus our distributed file system
here you can see that a big table no it
manages data without holding on to the
data in Colossus so BigTable nodes have
exclusive readwrite access to sections
of the data in a table to provide the
atomicity of updates to a single row so
every row in BigTable was exclusively
managed by at most one node knows don't
talk to each other so there are no
crossroad transactions in this case but
this allows for variable scalability
here the ABCD and E are sorted key
ranges within a single table so as we
mentioned earlier the storage model
sorts the keys in the table to allow you
for fast linear scans now let's say we
have a single node that is getting a lot
of activity because there's a lot of
popular data that is being accessed by a
bunch of clients what BigTable can do is
simply reassign the ownership of the
data to a different node and that is an
online operation without any data motion
so regardless of the gigabytes or
terabytes of data that you've just
reassigned this is an online operation
and without any data copying the data
stays exactly where it was in Colossus
and this is just a metadata update to
show that there's new owner of this data
and the request flow automatically the
client is completely unaware of this
because their requests are automatically
forwarded by the load balancing proxy
layer that I mentioned earlier so
clients don't need to do any discovery
or any updates or management of who'd
way they need to connect to they have a
single endpoint they connect to that and
the requests are routed automatically
even when the data is rebalanced and
reassigned at scale this ability to
easily reassign the data and the strong
separation between the processing
storage it Mable's the simple
scalability that Steve mentioned earlier
which what this means is that if we add
another node to the cluster as you can
see here we can easily shard and
reassign the data to other nodes and so
the cluster will scale
in performance in linear order compared
with a number of nodes in the cluster
you don't have to do anything to enable
this you just add more nodes to the
cluster you get the additional
throughput in the cluster given the size
of nodes
similarly of course you can shrink down
the cluster and we will again resize and
rebalance the assignments to fit that
smaller cluster what this means is that
you can get you can get seamless
scalability in scaling for cloud
BigTable without any downtime and as
Steve alluded you get the linear
scalability if you have good schema
design now what does that mean to have
good schema design we'll talk about this
in a bit as to how you can get good
schema design and what it actually means
for big tip on what perform as well but
before we get to that let's talk about
some of the recent features that we've
announced for a big table yesterday we
announced the cloud pick that will now
support your application and it is now
generally available there are no manual
steps to enable replication and
synchronization or any steps to repair
data or anything to synchronize on you
writes or deletes this is automatically
handled for you as soon as you add
another cluster to an instance and some
of the use cases that you might consider
for this are either high availability
for serving or workload separation for
batch and serving use cases as I
mentioned it's GA as of yesterday it
increases the SLA from 99 five to ninety
nine nine five and a zero touch failure
for H a so with that let's return a bit
to the role scheme and design and how
that impacts performance as Steve
mentioned good rule key schema design is
crucial for performance to get the
linear scalability because the role key
schema design will guide the access
patterns and you want to make sure that
your access patterns scale linearly to
enable the scaler this linear scaling
for the performance in your BigTable
cluster if you have uneven access
patterns you'll end up with hotspots if
you're storing too much data due to the
Ross key schema design in a single row
you also have a you have trouble doing
that because since we cannot split a
single row across multiple nodes in
BigTable
you will have single servers that are
really hard trying to serve a single
role that may be gigabytes in size so in
the end you really want balanced access
banners you want really Shinobi size
rows and that will provide the linear
scalability that you have with a
BigTable traditional monitoring involves
line charts such as this one where you
can look at CPU utilization you
see latency you can see data stored and
such so this will show you for example
this graph CPU utilization you know on
average and in a cluster we also have CP
utilization for the hottest node in your
cluster which might hint at a
possibility of hotspots but what if you
wanted to know more what if you wanted
to see what is actually happening under
the covers and how is it that you can
improve your Voki schema design to
improve performance how would you know
if you have large rows how would you
know that there's a MapReduce that may
be affecting your serving latency how
would you do bug if you really have high
CPU and find what the cause of that high
CPU might be with that I want to hand it
over to him he'll talk about a new
feature for cloud BigTable key
visualizer when Thank You Michel good
morning everyone my name is wim de PO
I'm the engineering manager of the
visual analytics team in New York and
very proud to announce key visualizer
for cloud BigTable this is a novel
approach to analyze the behavior of your
table you saw the line chart before well
typical line charts they only show one
dimension we shall read and write access
patterns both over time and the key
space this will help you find and
prevent hotspots you can find rows with
too much data and you can see if your
key schema is balanced this is the heat
map of key visualizer it will show time
horizontally it proceeds from left to
right this example shows one week of
behavior of your BigTable the key space
is shown vertically with the lowest keys
at the bottom and the highest keys at
the top then there's the heat scale you
can see it has colors from cold in black
4-0 and then it goes to dark blue red
yellow to glowing white hot for
extremely high values in this example
here you can see a diurnal pattern you
see this lowest key range over here well
there's about seven hotspots here so
someone must have hammered that key
range very heavily every night over
there you see a cold area because it's
practically completely dark
and this horizontal line in the middle
that is glowing white must be a key that
has been used very very heavily in this
example here you see a diagonal line
which is probably a sequential scan from
a MapReduce job and then if you keep
visualizer if you hover with the mouse
over the screen you'll see in the
tooltip more details like the actual
value the precise time and then deed the
start and the end key of the region that
you're hovering over around the heat map
you'll see at the bottom and on the
right
aggregate values in bar charts so here
at the bottom you see averages over the
visible key space in 15-minute intervals
this is pretty much what you would see
in your traditional line chart on the
right side here there's another bar
chart that shows you averages over
visible time range per key range you see
that spike over here remember that was
that bright yell at that bright white
line of that hot key that we had in the
middle now when we were observing
BigTable application developers at
Google we observed that very often
although not always they were creating
their keys in a hierarchical value in a
hierarchical way so they were using
prefixes and concatenating these
prefixes a little bit like this example
this example here uses slashes and
dashes it could be other symbols too and
so we thought we're gonna in key
visualizer extract the prefix tree so
that you can see your key schema in the
heat map so the result of that will show
will look something like that
so here you see an icicle chart and the
leftmost tall thin rectangle here shows
you the top prefix and then as you go
right you see prefixes going down the
hierarchy why is this useful well first
of all you can now see your key schema
of the data that you design
and hopefully you can recognize the data
that you stored that way the other thing
is that we often observed that behavior
is correlated with the key layout so in
this example here this is a very small
key range and you see that corresponds
to a series of key prefixes here and
it's a very distinct pattern you see
this on-and-off pattern over four days
over here all correlated with the key
prefix key visualizer gives you 11
metrics first of all we give you ops
which is the sum of reads and writes
then we give you three warning metrics
that can point you to possibly bad
performance I'll talk about that later
on then we have reads writes we have
performance metrics like latency and
finally we have the amount of data that
is stored per row let me show you now
some common key access patterns so over
here you see an imbalance key space
again remember time goes horizontally
from left to right and you see that
about 20 percent of the top keys here
were very heavily used they're glowing
yellow and red whereas the 80% at the
bottom they're barely used because you
can see that it's very cold in this
example you see that your database was
pretty much cold over the whole key
spectrum up then all of a sudden at this
time you see a very sudden increase for
a key range from here to here when we
look at that example here you see that
everything is pretty much cold except
for a cube glowing white keys so that's
an example of a couple of hotspots that
we see here and then finally in this
example this is the same example that I
pointed you out in the previous slides
here you see this diagonal line which is
probably a sequential read caused by a
MapReduce job now key visualizer is not
just about visualization it's also about
analysis
analysis on possibly trillions of metric
values so imagine if you have a database
with a trillion rows if we want to show
that behavior on your laptop we have to
down sample and aggregate it in one way
or another right to get it to your
laptop in less than a minute so we have
to aggregate and down sample all these
performance metrics then on the other
hand we also analyze every single
performance value that we collect in the
system and they're very detailed the
result of that is three metrics the
first one is the read pressure index and
that is a function and opaque function
of read CPU read queue length which is
the number of read operations waiting to
be executed and latency and that
function can point you to possibly bad
read performance we have something
similar for write behavior and then
finally we have large rows which will
point you to any rows that contain more
than one gigabyte of data now this is a
massive amount of calculations and data
that we analyzed but the good news is
that this has absolutely no performance
impact on your cluster absolutely not
and it's all for free this is an example
here of a high read pressure you see
this glowing spot now some of you may
think well this may be a little bit
overwhelming because I have 11 metrics I
have all that data where do I start
we made it easy for you so when you're
open key visualizer it opens with ops
that's the default metric and what it
shows you is just an overview of your
activity you see if there's any hot
regions and cold regions if you have any
diurnal patterns any linear scans and
then you'll see if there is any warnings
at the top bar if there aren't any
warnings that's good news then there's
nothing to do you can just relax if
there are warnings
and they will show up like this example
over here then you click on the button
to see which keys and when they were
causing problems I'm going to show you
an example now so imagine your open key
visualizer in the ops view you see an
overview of your behavior this is one
week and you see what's hot and what is
called and the diurnal patterns and over
there which I've annotated in the red
rectangle you see this read pressure
warning it has a three exclamation mark
so that means it's severe I click on
that button and it brings me immediately
to the read pressure index metric you
see this glowing white stripe over here
so when I hover over it with the tooltip
and she immediately the details of the
problems so I've got a list of problems
here but the most severe one is the one
at the top here which are validated to
Utley the red rectangle and I'm going to
zoom in into that now so what is this
well you see it's glowing so it's it's
bad so first of all this is a single key
and it's been stressed for two hours and
a half that's pretty long the other
thing which you can see is the exact
name of the offending key shown over
here in the second line and why do we
think that it's bad well look at the
total read CPU it's using four hundred
and forty six million nodes which is
roughly half a server worth of CPU
remember this is just for one key right
and then we also give the potential
culprit the suggestion of what probably
was causing this while we're dealing
with a large row here so look at this
this is ten point thirty eight gigabyte
and you know that the recommended row
size the maximum row size in BigTable is
256 megabyte
so this is way too much of course once
you imagine someone is hammering that
key very hard pulling out all that data
and each time they're pulling out ten
gigabytes so no wonder that this is
going to use a lot of CPU
see this is how easy it was I open key
visualizer I look at the overview click
on the alarm the alert buttons and it
shows me the the problem what we've
shown you so far our metrics that are
showing our views that are showing one
metric for example opps and you can
imagine that you're looking at a read
hot spot and you may want to know while
I'm also writing at this time and space
and place and you switch to writing and
then you want to see is there any
latency and you switch to latency and so
this was a little bit cumbersome we
thought to make this a little bit easier
so this new feature which we probably
will launch in a couple of weeks from
now is the multiple metrics view so here
in the middle you see what we had before
when I hover o with my cursor over an
area I see in the tooltip the values but
now at the same time I see all the
metric values for each metric over there
on the right side so that's this lets
you compare and correlate metrics
simultaneously just in one view in this
example here you see that the reads that
are in purple they're somewhat lukewarm
whereas the writes they're bright yellow
so we're doing not so much reading but
all of writing in this example and then
there's the expand all button over there
so if I click on that one this will
bring up miniature views for each metric
that are showing the same window as the
main view so here I had opps over there
I had the number of bytes written over
here I have the number of data stored
and here the number of rows and if I
hover with the cursor over the main view
the cursor will simultaneously change
over here and you see the corresponding
metrics also if i zoom in and out and if
I pan in the main view all of these view
will just move and we'll be zooming in
synchronized so that will be coming in a
couple of weeks
let me summarize - if you again be a
couple of the benefits that I
demonstrated so far so it helps you
detect and prevent key axis hotspots it
helps you find large rows more than one
gigabyte and there's no performance
impact for you at all and it's free one
use case that I did not illustrate over
here is how to optimize your key schema
and that's what Steve is now gonna talk
about because he used key visualizer for
that purpose thank you
so as we introduced now we're gonna talk
about how we use this feature while we
were developing our analytics product in
order to tune in really optimize the
data so one of the things we realized
while we were building this is that the
the key schema and the row key schema
really matters a lot for how well the
performance of your BigTable will be
again poorer key schema design will end
up with a very non scalable BigTable
design so a few common things that we
realized we need to do is that we should
tune our data to the query patterns that
we were expecting which kind of makes
sense so and building our row keys we
basically want the queries the
dimensions in those queries to match the
row key from left or from left to right
so you have some dimensions you put them
in your row key in a serialized form you
want to be able to match them left to
right to get optimum data query in your
in your queries also you want your row
keys to be well distributed across the
whole key space otherwise you're not
gonna have a very linearly scalable
system because only certain nodes will
be serving a majority of the data and
also you want your queries to have the
minimum number of scans required in
order to make it to keep your commonly
accessed data together
um so what we're gonna do now is I'm
gonna introduce just an example kind of
toy schema that's a simplified version
of what we use for our actual advertiser
analytics and we'll walk through some
simulated traffic on it and see what
they look like in key schema in key
visualizer and how we improved the
design um so here's some simple
dimensions um you can imagine advertiser
ID is just the ID we give any advertiser
that signs up with us a campaign ID is a
campaign they're running so maybe it's
an ad they're showing something like
that time stamp is the the time the data
that we're querying corresponds to um
generally we we group things into an
hour granularity so the time stamp will
be at the hour level engagement type is
just kind of like what the user did to
engage with the ad to be view it did
they click on it do they install an
application something like that and then
display location is where it was on the
page like was it in their timeline was
it a search result things like that so
basically our first iteration was really
simple so let's take all of these
dimensions concatenated together from
left to right and that becomes our okey
so time Sam advertiser ID campaign ID
etc etc um there's some pros here um
it's really easy to scan across all
advertisers if you have a time range and
generally all of our careers will have a
time range in them you have good data
locality cuz all the data for an
advertiser is grouped together but now
let's check out the cons so this is a
view of what are our key schema or our
key visualizer looks like with this
schema this isn't great so we have here
there's a big spa basically no traffic
up here you can see there's a very
pronounced line of hot keys which
generally will correspond to the current
week of data we're looking at here most
of the queries for our data that we have
are querying for the most recent data
that makes sense people care more about
what's happening now and then what
happen in the past so this is great this
is not a really good design if we had
run this in production we'd probably
have very hot notes all the time because
whatever node was hosting this small key
range in the middle here would be
overloaded all the time so let's iterate
let's let's take what we learned here um
and see what we can do so we learned
timestamp was not great to put in the
front so let's swap timestamp in
advertiser ID well this is going to do
now is the advertiser ID is at the
beginning of Mikey and the timestamp is
it wasn't within there so it's still
easy to scan for a time range within an
advertiser it's harder to query for all
advertisers however in our use cases
that's not really something we care
about you advertisers coming in are only
looking at their data obviously we're
not gonna let them query for anything so
although we we have a con here it's not
really the end of the world it doesn't
really fit our use case anyways so let's
look at what happened here we got a
little better so the there's there's
more distribution however we still have
some hotkeys um some hot ranges here
these most likely will correspond to
advertisers that are more frequently
querying for their data additionally our
advertiser ID keys might not be very
well distributed across the entire key
space they're probably sequentially
generated integers or something so in
that case we'll end up with groupings of
like we probably generated a bunch of
IDs here and then here and those are all
groups of ad factors so let's iterate
again we've learned that we put out in
front of advertiser ID in front things
worked out a little better um however we
didn't get a good distribution on that
advertiser ID key space so instead let's
reverse the advertiser ID basically the
first digit is now the last digit which
will basically synthetically distribute
the keys a lot better because now
instead of the most significant bit
that's generally not changing much you
have the least significant bit which is
always cycling all the time because
we're if they're sequentially generated
IDs so pros and cons are basically the
same now there's not not a big
difference other than you couldn't scan
advertiser IDs sequentially but we don't
care that's not a use case anyways so
this is what we end up with everything
looks pretty good um we still have some
some rows here which correspond probably
to more more frequently accessed
advertisers that are polar
their data more but in general the key
space is really well distributed across
basically the entire the entire range
this is what we want it to look like um
and and this will lead to a really well
performing design so the really
important thing here is because we were
able to do this it really gave us
confidence that when we took this
product and went live with it that we
wouldn't end up with like horrible
performance issues and we don't have to
redesign it in a year because it
wouldn't scale it's also been really
helpful for us if we have a production
issue come up like Oh like why is our
latency going up for certain advertisers
or things like that we can go right into
key visualizer and see what's happening
at the time and now I'm gonna hand it
over to Misha
so as you use as you've seen Steve at
Twitter was able to use BigTable add the
scale that Twitter needs to do visual
analytics and serve their ads analytics
big table provides the fully managed no
sequel database to serve these types of
use cases for time series user analytics
as well as others it provides a petabyte
scale scalability for storage high
throughput and low latency for random
access and it provides the ability to
seamlessly redistribute the data to
handle increases in load and seamless
scalability for while adjusting to the
access patterns that you can put on it
and you can learn more about it at the
URL so key visualizer which is a beta
now for cloud BigTable visualizes your
key access patterns it will help you
find hotspots and large rows and it's
not just visualization we also analyzed
trillions of metric values it extracts
the pre the key prefix hierarchy if it's
available and it doesn't have any impact
on the performance of your cluster
there's URL here that you can go to for
more information and then finally some
of the really key features on that
BigTable and key visualizer enabled for
us at Twitter it really gave us a very
fast time to market on bringing this new
improved advertiser analytics product up
to scale
additionally like using key visualizer
gave us really good confidence that we
would be able
to scale up and and end up with a
scalable design system we were able to
iterate on the roki design way faster
than we would have been if we had to
infer it through other metrics like p99
latency things like that and then
finally it made it really easy to change
the roki schema during development and
just see what happened it let us iterate
really quickly um but without going live
in production and actually having to
worry about impacting that so that's all
we have thank you very much
you